uh putting migrants on barges and in
disused military air bases well we'll
look at the detail that we've just heard
it this morning I have to say I've heard
this announcement several times before
from the conservatives and one might be
cynical and say well there's a local
elections coming up they would say this
wouldn't they I mean our concern is
they're not dealing with the fundamental
problems the fundamental problems is
they're not processing applications
quick enough they haven't been doing
that for several years now that creates
this problem of people in hotels and if
they did process more quick if it's the
real Basics right either people would be
accepted as refugees and could start
work and contributing society and pay
tax or they would be deported but by
this holding position by failing to do
the basics right the conservatives are
failing these people and they're failing
the whole country
they try to sort that out you do you
think that it's appropriate that the tax
payers spending something like seven
billion pounds a day on hotels for
migrants well if we can reduce that bill
ideally by doing the job properly in the
first place that would obviously be much
more preferable this is a sign of
government failure let's be really clear
about this if the government tackle this
problem as they've been urged to a long
time ago we wouldn't boom where we are
now
um you know we've argued not just for
processing getting the bureaucracy right
we've argued for safe and legal routes
for years the government beginning to
talk about it but if they'd done what
we'd argued for a few years ago we
wouldn't have the problem now
we are being told that the overseas aid
budget is being used to to pay for
migrants to be held in hotels and that
is something like three and a half
billion pounds a year a third of the
overseas aid budget what you thought on
that again this shows the costs of the
conservative failure if the concerns
have got to grips this years ago as we
had been argued little Democrats putting
for practical Solutions if they'd
adopted our Solutions Not only would we
not have this problem with the hotels
that we have now we wouldn't be using
the aid budget for something that wasn't
really meant for I think there'd be a
lot of your views and taxpayers who
pretty cross that um people who really
need help in in developing countries by
the way that might stop people wanting
to come in the first place we actually
spent the money where it was supposed to
do solving the problem at root
um people will be angry that the
government are spending their money in
the way that it wasn't originally
intended to do talk to me about the NHS
we've seen this survey it's not good it
has to be said for satisfaction levels
on the NHS but perhaps even more
concerning is the cost of an NHS dentist
is likely to rise by eight and a half
percent next month what impact do you
think that will have on your
constituents in the right wider country
Dreadful I mean my decisions have a real
problem finding an NHS dentist in the
first place and when you look at that
satisfaction you said it wasn't good
it's absolutely appalling I've never
known the NHS in such a crisis in my
time in in public service and you know
whether it's getting a GP appointment
whether it's access to NHS dentist
whether it's waiting times and a e
cancer treatment waiting times they've
all gone gone very bad Direction and the
government seem totally out of touched
aren't getting a grip of this and the
reality is people are suffering you know
um when I've been camping around the
country I was in Yorkshire the other
week I was in Surrey uh recently too
people are saying the NHS is the biggest
issue and they're worried about their
loved ones they worry about their
families they're worried that they're
having to wait way too long for an
ambulance for example and this is the
reality and
you know the government seems to want to
talk about everything else other than
how they're going to sort our Health
Service out and what liberal Democrats
are saying the local elections in
Community Arts Community let's our local
Health Services because that's what
people want to see and it's almost as if
the government are living in another
planet they just aren't getting to grips
with the real problems
um launching a new campaign today tell
us about it yeah we've got the low
collections in May
yeah last year liberal Democrats had a
great result we made more gains than any
other political party from Seven local
elections were England Scotland and
Wales so we go into these local
elections uh very positive
um and we've got uh local candidates up
and down the country knocking on
people's doors talking to them and
wanting to serve their local communities
as local Champions and the NHS is coming
up big as I've just described so it's
the cost of living uh people feel the
government just haven't done enough to
help them with their energy bills for
example I think the other big issue is
the environment
um people have been shocked when we've
discovered the government have have
haven't been strict enough on the water
companies who are pumping their filthy
sewage into rivers up and down the
country we need to get tough on these uh
water companies government needs to stop
helping them out and needs to really set
a real lead on this so whether it's the
NHS whether it's cost living whether
it's environment these are the issues
that people need to
and I think liberal Democrats are
providing them how do you feel about the
new leader of the SNP a man you can do
business with well I've never met him uh
and I'm very keen to meet him at some
stage I've talked to my Scottish
colleagues um Alex call Hamilton the
liberal Democrat leader of in Scotland
and my Scottish diploma MPS
um we feel the real problem with Hamza
Yusuf and the SMP is they want to break
up the family of our of the United
Kingdom and that they're so obsessed
with Independence they're not focusing
on the real issues that the Scottish
people are facing which by the way are
very similar to the issues that English
people face whether it's the Health
Service which is in a mess in Scotland
and and was actually in charge of that
and he's really failed on the NHS
whether it's the Police Service in
Scotland which is is performing quite
badly he was a Justice secretary and
oversaw some of that so he doesn't have
a very good record of dealing with the
issues that really mattered to people
and whether in Scotland or or England
we're seeing two governments that have
been focused on their own sort of
ideological nationalist agenda and not
focused on the the issues that matter to
Ordinary People and what liberal
Democrats are going to do in this set of
local elections as we campaign
throughout the country uh very positive
you have to say
um we're going to show people that we
have a lot of the same concerns that
they have and we want to tackle them so
red it's always great to see you thanks
for taking the time thank you very much
thank you